I make more money than your entire
family tree will ever make you ain't
[__] kid you will never be [__] ever for
the rest of your life enjoy that Walmart
job I think Mo is right I think yeah I
can understand how they could take
offense to that because now you're
insulting the people that you're
marketing it to both of us didn't think
it was a it was an issue it's not I no I
it's not com but my point is it's not
the behavior it's who's doing it based
off the brand 100 and that's pokey's
fault because in the past she's try to
play this diplomatic respectability
think if it's me and I make the mistake
she made and audiences are roasting me
in my chat best believe I'm going to
roast them back I don't care and I'm not
going to apologize fing to the Moon
[__] let's talk about this pokem man
situation cuz the way the cookie has
crumbled in this situ I hate myself
you're saying it that way she just
launched a new snack company called Mina
snacks specifically releasing
gluten-free cookies made with natural
ingredients and no preservatives and
there was initially some backlash about
how the cookies were made if she just
stuck her branding on an already
existing product which she denied and
well that aspect this whole thing is
kind of played out today's controversy
has to do with the price of the cookies
because it costs $28 for a pack of four
bags you know some people with that
think what you're smacking your name on
a brand that exists that's what [__]
most of the product that you
consume that's what they are you mean
they're mostly just Rebrand a lot of
them are a lot of product supplements
are often like that supplements will
literally just have a fitness guy come
in and just stick his name on the [__]
and that's it
most I'm not it's just it's really not
knowing how all this and how Bamboozled
some of you guys are like don't
get don't get oh my God he got his new
some he's got his new brand of cognac
often time it was a brand of cognac that
was already existing the production is
there but they're not able to get there
so they slap a name of someone that they
actually know that's going to be able to
be called
conac you have to be from the region of
France that is conac the conac region of
France if it's not that from that region
it is not conac so just to put the stamp
cognac on it it has to come from that
region I really
doubt that ludicrous is from cognac but
he has a brand so what do you think and
and I and I've tasted the Kure I've
tasted it it's a great brand but if you
look on the bottom of the bottle it
tells you where it's from and from what
house it was made from and if it's made
from a house it means it already existed
and all those alcohol Brands were all
it's it's all like alcohol is the worst
for that hey you be surprised
supplemental Justice the fitness guys
are crazy about grabbing someone else's
[__] and Rebrand and because people
trust this Fitness person all of a
sudden the supplement sell again and not
that person it's the same thing it's the
same thing and sometimes they're going
to change flavored names yes keep been
criticizing her and all of this appear
to get so much bigger because she
seemingly addresses over the weekend say
when people are like oh my God $28 for
cookies it's four
bags that's seven $7 a bag I know I know
math is
hard when you're an idiot
but like if you're a broke boy just say
so like if you're a broke boy just say
so anyways moving
on if you want to play eight pay $8 for
Twitter blue for some pixels that's okay
that's
fine you spend your money how you
want I'll spend mine how and everyone
else will spend theirs how they want
that's with people getting absolutely
pissed about her comment they're saying
things light these streamers are getting
so out of touch with reality it's
actually disgusting and I love when
streamers get so rich that they start
calling their fans dumb and poor it's so
awesome and listen if I ever become a
millionaire and start calling my
audience broke just beat me up I give
you all permission right now even big
names like Mo critical chiming it I
don't know what would possess her to say
something so rude and nasty to the
audience she is trying to sell this
product to your wealth was built on
their backs so it is also worth noting
that I think Mo is right I think both
think and Co I think Mo is right I think
yeah I can understand how they could
take offense to that because now you're
insulting the people that you're
marketing it to you know what I mean my
understanding is like after the product
came out like [__] were on her
ass like everybody was doing it and
saying foul stuff to her and so the
understanding I had was that in her live
stream chat there's a lot of people
losing it being like how dare you sell
these cookies L and that and that and so
she ended up snapping yeah I understand
the snapping I understand the snapping
situation because when this thing happen
you have tunnel vision of what that is
but the reality is not the majority of
the people you're watching we saying
that the trolls is something that you're
going to see right it's not necess going
to be the majority when there's a lot of
it you're only going to see that and the
trolls are the one that speak loudly so
you think they're even more than they
are there was a time where I thought
there was more trolls than they are you
know what I
mean I was like oh my God it's a l and I
had to stop watching comments that was
way back when we started you know what I
mean and you really think there's more
than that because these are the more
vocal ones and I understand it's
snapping but in the end of the day
you're trying to do some marketing you
can't [__] the people that you're
marketing it to I mean you can it's just
probably it's probably not great for the
brand no it's not great for the brand so
it's like why would you do that you
trying to sell it to them you're calling
them idiots so it's not the best way but
I understand the snap some people did
defend her saying this just another case
of people finding an excuse to call her
out arguing if you can't afford the
cookies don't buy them it's so simple
this girl launches some cookies cookies
and the whole world's on fire but actual
problematic streamers do wild [__] and
yall stay shut and as someone with
celiac disease I spend anywhere from 5
to $10 for a single bag of certified
gluten-free cookies every time I shop
this pricing is normal for gluten-free
goodies y'all just love to
hate let's start with just the product
first the product is like the biggest
non-issue folks talking about oh it's a
Rebrand the ingredients are the same you
don't know what the ratios are it is
possible that they modified the recipe
completely like a lot of brands for
cookies are going to have the exact same
um ingredient list what's going to make
the ingredients taste different is how
you blend them in the ratios of the
Blends no but let's say even if it is
identical that is what creators and what
influencers and what celebrities do now
they slap their name on a brand okay if
they think the brand is good and then
from there that's it now my
understanding is this brand has a small
amount of vitamin D that's one of the
major differences as well as like some
of the flavoring but let's say I grant
it to you guys let's say it is an
identical prodct prodct that is what
most of these people are doing you
buying merch you do realize they're all
using merch from the exact same T-Shirt
Company the only difference is these
[__] slapped their own little
logo on top of it and now it's supposed
to be substantially different even
though they're all charging anywhere
from 30 to 50 to $60 more for the exact
same shirts and hoodies right all of a
sudden now even those exact same company
with the same cotton same everything
balance it doesn't matter because it's
their product and has their logo on it
now the Whole Health aspect of it how
healthy are these cookies are they
really worth the price do I think so no
but if I go to my
store if I go to the store and I go to
the health section literally everything
cost just as much if not more I don't
really care that a Creator comes out
with a horribly overpriced product
because what's overpriced to me is right
in the range of others and that's just
how it is and at the end of day if I
don't want some I don't buy I don't care
if creators want want to tell their fans
like hey you guys can donate $500 to
support me my only issue is it's like
that Invader V girl where she's telling
her fans if you don't buy this [__]
you're a loser if you if she's shaming
people into it that's a different
conversation it ain't about the product
it ain't about someone donating to some
booby streamer it's not that it's you
shaming your audience who are watching
you to giving you their money it's okay
that's
fine you spend your money how you
want I'll spend mine how I want and
everyone else will spend theirs how they
want that's a beauty the reason I don't
like I don't care about the branding
thing is that that's what branding is
any product that you have any produc we
actually buy
produ forget comparing one to another
just one product we buy it because of
The Branding that's how our brain works
that's how branding works we buy it
because there's a color we buy it the if
you enter in any Market any uh grocery
store it's placed to the same this video
is brought to you by surf shark while
fresh and fit just pearly things and
every the loser in the red pill space
are taking L's we want you guys to get
some W's with today's sponsor surf shark
here's the thing a lot of stuff is
linked to your IP address and your
personal information right you want to
book a flight well depending on your IP
address you might get different rates
that's right if you try to book the
flight from London versus Brazil versus
Canada you're going to get three
different sets of prices depending on
the fair that you're trying a book but
with the VPN changer you can optimize
your travel plans by making sure that
they cannot track your IP to give you an
unfavorable Fair what's more some
content is gated based off your location
why shouldn't you be able to watch the
TV shows and the movies you want to
watch when you got a subscription you
should be able to see it all just
changing your location with a VPN allows
you to do so and what's more if you're
going to be on public Wi-Fi if you're
going to be out here you need to protect
your information and so surf sharks VPN
service actually serves to protect your
devices what's more what makes surf surf
shark really special is that you can
connect multiple devices to the same
account it's now time for you guys to
take advantage and right now if you
click on the link below and use uh the
promo code ab and preach you're going to
be able to have up to six months free
click on the link in the description
below it's your turn you know what I
mean the the sugary cereals are going to
be at a certain level Heights of the
kids so that they see it uh you're going
to see the fruits first you're going to
see the vegetable it's the affect the
way you buy and putting someone on a a
recipe that exists is just the same
thing as a color as a scent as a brand
as a as a as a shape so to me I really
don't care about that because of that oh
my God she took her recipe that yes
toucan sand is not a real person but it
sells okay it's like it's a recipe that
already existed and slap the two can on
it you know what I mean just to make it
great no pun intended but everybody
likes that that's the same exact idea we
put a mascot on a product to sell
it that's it all
right yeah no you're right listen like
it's just to let you guys know this is
the world of marketing and brands in
general if your creator coming out with
a new pair of shoes best believe they
weren't in the kitchen cooking them up
and doing everything like that Michael
Jordan was not like I you know what we
could use I was studying while I was
dunking this mcle form that we could
just make the form a no that's not his
department and here's the [__] up part
it doesn't even mean the product is bad
no that's not because a product could be
great but because it doesn't have a good
name attachment for the marketing it
just dies out before it even hits the
market so there's no way it really know
unless you tried the cookies out and
done this whole thing all I'm going to
say is this okay I think this this thing
blowing up the way it did initially cuz
she brought up some cookies that some
people think are overpriced is
ridiculous all right I'm telling you
right now your favorite Creator every
day are coming out with shitty [__]
products all the time the fact that this
was a big story I didn't understand at
first and I didn't really care her
roasting the fans like that and say that
[__] you want to feel as disrespectful I
got no problem me personally I'm not mad
at people who get mad at her because I
think she's built a brand of kind of
being familyfriendly so anytime she says
anything [__] be like snapping
on her but me personally I'm a big fan
of Tyler 1 the way this man talks to his
audience is crazy he calls him
fatherless he calls him anything under
the sun stop
crying you couldn't make me stop ever
you
little [__] kid literally right in the
ass you little keep going all day I make
more money than your entire family tree
will ever make you ain't [__] kid you
will never be [__] ever for the rest of
your life enjoy that Walmart job and
enjoy Sil for life you're never going to
be anything ever and it's your parents
desp your entire existence they go to
bed cry every
single he's a streamer okay very popular
the best what's his name Tyler one Tyler
one yeah that is hilarious oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you would die last okay
thank the go recognizing game okay okay
yeah foul to his audience yeah but
that's his stream and that that's is
going to stay there but my point is it's
not the behavior it's who's doing it
based off the brand and that's pokey's
fault because in the past she's trying
to play this diplomatic respectability
thing if it's me and I make the mistake
she made and audiences are roasting me
in my chat best believe I'm going to
roast them back I don't care and I'm not
going to apologize either and they're
going to know and my audience is not
going to care either there's people
right now on Twitch all over the
platform who are huge who roast Their
audience on a regular basis okay it's
different if you shame your audience uh
into buying your product because they
don't want to but if your audience is
talking [__] and you talking [__] back I
ain't got no problem personally and I
don't think that's something worth
apologizing we could agree to disagree
you don't have to like those kind of
creators me personally there's a lot of
people who wouldn't [__] with my
temperament right I can get away with
saying [__] and [__] this and [__] that
where some blue-haired feminist dude
can't say that cuz his audience is going
to destroy him for talking crazy who you
talking about oh my girl Destiny
Okay
every every time you gave me the L how
you think about I I was not thinking
about her but then you brought it up so
I'm like
okay
um I'm just saying my girl dis I'm just
saying I think I I think it's a cute
name I think a lot of people dislike
Pokey because they perceive her as being
kind of fish or whatnot I Ain mad at it
because I think when people try to be
diplomatic and please everyone they come
across that way all right but you need
to just say what you thinking cuz I
don't even think you're really sorry and
the people I don't think you think what
you did is that wrong but it is wrong
want know why cuz you built your brand
though that way it's wrong it's going
against your marketing yeah go against
your marketing so again marketing again
you can Market dooo cookies you can't
Market Health cookies and they come with
doooo and then you want to act surprised
like and nothing happened no no you
helped Market these healthy cookies why
they got dooo stains on them that's you
that's you you can't do that both of us
didn't think it was a it was an issue
it's not I know it's not that comment
how many creators take sh but but the
the thing that happened as well is
that all you guys following people and
watching people thank you very much for
that but because you follow people and
you're you're so much invested you guys
really feel entitled and you entitled to
say the foulest [__] sometimes it's like
when you say some stuff to your creators
you go off yep but when they clap back
you're like oh my God I'm offended like
you really feel entitled behind that
little that that that that that that
computer saying whatever you want to say
because you're nous but you go some you
go on some foul things but when we clap
back and or we or we see Yo Yo I had
someone to tell me on stream yo dance
monkey I said [__] if you don't get the
[__] up out of here of course you're and
this person wrote me like three pages
cuz I said [__] I said you told me to
dance you better [__] off yourself
I don't and people really try to come at
me like yo why' you say that I say yo
[__] you too yes 100% you you like y' be
talking crazy like I'm not human I try
to be respectful with everybody but
y'all want to say crazy [__] and then
come at me like you didn't say that n i
out there you really out there saying
some foul foul foul foul [__] yes and
then when we clap back you're like oh my
God shut the [__] up yep like I said you
gonna say some crazy [__] I'm G say some
crazy [__] too and if you sort of happen
to leave leave [__] yeah don't let that
door hit you in the ass don't even
announce it I'm
unsubscribing the [__] out of here yeah
okay you say some foul [__] I'mma say
some foul [__] too if you see me in the
street and you say some foul [__] I'mma
say some foul [__] too listen all I'm
say this most of the people I meet are
very respectful and cool yes okay my
fans like I I see y times and I'm always
grateful cuz most y'all never give me no
issues and you're respectful so I'm had
to take pictures chitchat a little bit
whatever it might be okay some of y'all
[__] so but it's very small
minority all I'm saying is this I think
this is an issue because it's pokeon one
because of her brand but also because
some people have [__] derangement
syndrome when it comes to this girl they
like everything this girl does becomes
like a big story even when it's not a
big deal that's what I think this is
nice gone wrong cuz you have to have a
standard now of always being nice in
Jesus Christ that's hard some [__] that
are not so nice out there and you're
still being well you know to sh people
are going to see it some way like I know
some people who got like 4050 videos
dedicated to to this girl for like just
the most minute [__] sometimes and I'm
like what what is like the like is this
girl fresh and fit did I miss the boat
on something I be watching some of these
drama like cuz I want to get it I want
some ad reue too because you know mean
she bringing the books and then I look
at this I'm like yo this ain't even a
story and you know I already hate ladies
so I should be covering this
first you what
huh you're Wilding I mean the red pill's
gone somebody going to take their place
oh wow get the [__] out of here man take
it
all get the [__] out of here with that
laugh too
man you know you know what the whole
Pokemon thing is it reminds me of like
Michael bé getting caught with hookers
versus like ludicrous getting caught
with hookers like one is get elicit
reaction the other one nobody's going to
K care about why because the brain is in
complete contrast wait what are you
saying the guy that says I got hoes and
every a CO get gets caught with hoes in
every nobody's going to be surprised
that's about it but if you climing to
the Moon
wh not that's the difference in brand
though that's what I'm trying to say and
all you people sending me Pokemon Clips
make sure it's a good drama bro don't be
send me this garbage like yo let me let
me know if she cheating on somebody and
calling men trash something like that
you know not just like uh Brokey boy
like I don't care Brokey boy that's what
you called the dude that's why everyone
lost it she said Brokey boy yeah if
you're a Brokey boy just don't buy them
she said if you're a broy boy or a
Brokey yo that's lowkey lit name shut
the [__] up yo broky boy on the
mic you are stupid broky boy on the mic
yeah it sounds like a [__] uh first
person Shooter's character yeah broy boy
x 557 h i mered
you let us know what you think in the
comments
below no
hey